now that you're with Geffen because
you're kind of like uh you're the type
of artist that
so far I feel like kind of
is a perfect like you're you being
independent matches your output because
you have a high output of Music
um
how's the adjustment going to be being
with a major label are you still going
to be able to drop as frequently as you
want or is it going to be like like oh
really cool with like the president of
my label and stuff like that so I'm cool
with everybody in my label I got a good
relationship so if they say something
don't make sense I know it probably
don't make sense because they've been
there before so I don't really you know
I don't
oh my mind just hold nothing doing
things the right way that's what I got
with the label it wasn't really about no
money it's really about being in the
rooms and taking my stuff to the next
level so if that's what I got to do to
take myself to the next level that's
what I just gotta do like have you put
any music out since signing is the
tweaking record through them or
that somebody leaked my song that's not
even your song you didn't put that out
though no so someone just uploaded that
on distro kids
that's really a snippet like I'll be
uploading my music sometimes like screen
recording it and somebody screen
recording my page and uploaded it under
your profile yeah like they got that off
my story what the [ __ ] they got that off
my story or screen recorded it and
uploaded I just told my labor like I
gotta tell you I gotta take that down
Somebody went out of the way made an art
for it and everything for sure that
shit's crazy that's like the new bootleg
[ __ ] like imagine like signing up for a
distro kit account and uploading someone
else's [ __ ]
they wouldn't really I wasn't never
gonna put that out for real
that's just something I went to the
studio and had some on my chest and I
want the rap about it but that's not I
wasn't gonna put that out damn you're
getting bootlegged on Spotify you know
for sure that's wild they gotta take
that down though yeah
damn what's so okay so uh your your
major label debut or slash project how I
didn't know you were sitting on probably
hundreds of songs
do you know what that's looking like yet
my EP come out Thursday night Friday
morning so the ep's already put together
what's it called we eat the most which
is obviously you know on your chain
there pushing a brand yeah sure how many
songs
what is eight one
eight records yeah who's on the album or
EP whatever we're calling it me just you
no no features I'm saving my my features
for another time I Really they want
if the team like wanted me to put
something up so I let them pick the
songs and put something out so they can
they said they want to defeat the fans
so
I don't know video shot video shot nice
three or four of them shot